Plenty of actors have starred in
movies or TV shows that most people
don't know about — but who ever
knew that Cameron Boyce did this?
The late Cameron Boyce once starred in
a movie back in 2008 that his fans have
likely forgotten about — especially those
who know him for his family-friendly work.
Boyce, who died in 2019, is most well-known for
his performances in a handful of Disney Channel
shows and movies that were released throughout the
2010s. Boyce began to earn some early attention
in 2011 when he landed the recurring role of
Luke Ross on the Debby Ryan-led series Jessie.
Boyce's fame continued to grow in
2015 when he appeared as Carlos,
the son of Cruella de Vil, in the Disney
Channel original movie Descendants. He
went on to reprise his role as Carlos
in three more Descendants movies.
Outside of his work for the Disney Channel,
Boyce also had notable recurring roles on
the HBO original series Mrs. Fletcher and the
Amazon Prime musical TV show Paradise City.
Long before he appeared in those TV shows,
however, Boyce made his big-screen
debut in a now-forgotten horror movie.
In 2008, Cameron Boyce starred as a young boy
named Michael in Alexandre Aja's supernatural
horror film, Mirrors. The film follows a
former cop as he and his family are targeted
by a malevolent force that is attempting to use
mirrors to make its way into the physical world.
"We gotta get going, okay?"
"Okay."
A remake of a 2003 South Korean
horror movie titled Into the Mirror,
this movie wasn't particularly well received by
critics or casual viewers when it was initially
released in 2008. While the movie managed to
more than double its $35 million production
budget at the box office, it currently boasts
a low 15% Tomatometer score on Rotten Tomatoes.
The film's audience score sits slightly higher at
44%, but that isn't high enough to earn Mirrors a
"Fresh" rating. In his review of the film for
Entertainment Weekly, Owen Gleiberman wrote:
"The director, Alexandre Aja, knows how
to reflect the fear in people's heads,
but he gets too ensnared in a backstory
that's just gothic business as usual."
However, in his write-up of the movie for Reel
Film Reviews, David Nusair actually praised
Mirrors, observing that it is, quote, "often far
more entertaining than it has any right to be."
Notably, Mirrors marked Boyce's first
and only horror movie. Fortunately,
it's quite clear that the film's poor reception
hasn't tainted Boyce's legacy in any tangible way.
At just 20 years old, Boyce died from epilepsy in
2019, cutting short his burgeoning screen career.
Boyce turned in his final screen performance
as Simon in the first season of Paradise City,
which premiered on Amazon nearly two full years
after his death. But despite the fact that Boyce's
career ended in 2019, his legacy continues to live
on. In fact, many of the actors and collaborators
with whom he worked over the years have been
consistently willing to sing his praises;
many have spoken openly about the positive
experiences that they shared with him.
Following Boyce's tragic death, several
of his most notable co-stars took to
social media to pay tribute to him.
Adam Sandler, for instance, tweeted:
"Too young. Too sweet. Too funny. Just the nicest,
most talented, and most decent kid
around. [...] Thank you, Cameron,
for all you gave to us. So much more was
on the way. All our hearts are broken."
In addition to Sandler, several of Boyce's
Disney Channel collaborators were also quick
to publicly pay their own tributes. Three years
after his death, Boyce's Descendants co-star,
Sofia Carson, even took a moment to
remember him, writing on Instagram:
"Three years without you. I love
you, forever. I miss you, forever."
Carson's post proves that, among other things,
the death of Boyce continues to be felt deeply
by both his fans and loved ones. And while Boyce
will no doubt be missed, there's no denying that
he left behind an impressive assortment of movie
and TV performances that his fans can continue
to enjoy for many years to come — including
his supporting turn as Michael in Mirrors.